castagna tel sera le nom du nouveau
centre aqualudique intercommunal de
maurepas et d'elancourt
le permis de construire a été signé ce
vendredi 18 septembre
l'événement marque le début des travaux
coût total du projet plus de 24 millions
d'euros
ce projet n'aurait jamais pu voir le
jour s'il n'y avait pas eu la confiance
entre nos deux villes amies maurepas ils
encourent et aussi avec l'ensemble de
nos partenaires puisque on a quand même
été des financièrement de manière très
importante un pas loin de 50 % de
financement public sur les 24 millions
d'euros que représente le projet on est
enchanté bien sûr aujourd'hui
signé un peu plus d'engagement sur ce
beau projet c'est à l'image des
nouvelles piscines qu'il va falloir
construire sur l'ensemble du territoire
le projet s'étend sur plus de 4000
mètres carrés avec cinq bassins sportifs
polyvalents ou encore à quoi lange
le bâtiment devrait consommer 20 %
d'énergies renouvelables il se veut
écologique est tourné vers le futur
cinq bassins tout en inox plus de
carrelage là qu'on aura aussi des
matériaux qui seront adaptés pour durer
dans le temps et nous coûter moins cher
en entretien et en fonctionnement et qui
rompt aussi la qualité de l'eau plus
appréciable quelque part mais aussi avec
une capacité de filtration qui
pourraient être différentes
c'est un projet qui fait la somme du
progrès des différentes technologies
pour gérer une piscine au moindre coût
et avec plus de qualité
la première pierre du centre aqualudique
sera posée fin octobre pour une
ouverture au public en avril à 2022